later today the CDC will release further
guidance to help ensure critical
infrastructure workers can perform their
job safely after potential exposure to
the virus and so they're working on that
the question was asked a little while
ago about the World Health Organization
and as you know they made a statement on
June 1 January 14th I guess it was that
there was no human to human transmission
while there was they probably made that
statement in the second or third week of
December in addition but they made it
very powerfully on January 14th and they
criticized me very strongly when I said
that we're going to shut down flights
coming in from China and especially from
certain parts of China but from China
generally we were criticized very badly
so last year and for many years hundreds
of millions of dollars has been paid to
the World Health Organization hundreds
of millions of dollars a year and last
year was 452 million dollars in China
paid 42 million before that it was 500
million in China paid less than 40
million and before that it was similar
numbers in the 400s 300s and sometimes
even in the 500s of millions of dollars
and China would do proportionally it's
just a small fraction of that number and
I think they have to get their
priorities right and their priorities
are that everybody has to be treated
properly every country and it doesn't
seem that way does it doesn't seem that
way so we're going to do study
investigation and we're going to make a
determination as to what we're doing in
the meantime we're holding back we're
going to we want to say very unfair so
the United States
452 million dollars compared to 42
million dollars that's to the World
Health Organization that's not good
that's not good not fair not fair at all
and other countries as you know also
gave very substantially less than the
United States and the world w-h-o World
Health got it wrong I mean they got it
very wrong in many ways they were wrong
they also minimized a threat very
strongly and not good